everything I see Joe Biden do and the
Democratic
establishment I I don't see any any
long-term planning I see them basically
just setting fire to the curtains before
they leave yeah I don't see the
long-term planning that's it does feel
like all like just kind of let's do
right now what's good for now no they're
like okay we're getting kicked out light
it up I knew a guy once who got evicted
from his apartment so he took Hershey's
syrup and he squirted it into the cracks
of every nook of the building yeah bad
guy and he was like this will teach him
and I'm like I think you already taught
him by not paying rent but this is the
idea like the Democrats they're getting
evicted so they're like Set Fire to the
whole thing